as always you can click on the timestamp
in the description as well as here to
skip this longish introduction the
theories of everything channel is back
with a new season starting with last
week's ama which will be in the
description
from this point forward there will be
new content approximately once a week
sometimes even more frequently today's
guests are carl fristen mike 11 and
chris field the former two have been on
this channel and mentioned several times
prior whereas chris fields is making his
debut chris fields is a researcher in
topological quantum field theory as well
as information theory and publishes work
on what constitutes an observer carl
fristin is a professor of neuroscience
at the university college london and is
the inventor of the free energy
principle michael levin is the
developmental and synthetic biologist at
the tufts university the links to all
their previous podcasts on the toad
channel will be in the description my
name is kurt jaymungal i'm a torontonian
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication quote unquote of the
variegated terrain of theories of
everything primarily from a theoretical
physics perspective but as well as
trying to understand what role does
consciousness have as constitutive
reality is it emergent is it fundamental
now the goals of theo locutions is to
interject seldomly if at all allowing
each guest to give their perspectives on
one another's thoughts essentially
giving us the experience of a fly on the
wall for the sorts of academic
conversations that would ordinarily
occur behind closed doors spurring
research in real time one of the central
issues of today's podcast is the concept
of babbling which i haven't heard
discussed virtually anywhere else
outside of child development or language
acquisition though it can be generalized
metaphorically perhaps even literally to
the vacuum fluctuations to interpret
what vacuum fluctuations are doing as an
indicator of the universe's
proto-consciousness that is the universe
babbling to understand itself but i
won't spoil the surprise if you'd like
to hear more podcasts like these then do
consider going to patreon.com
kurtjmungle as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to do this full time with regard to
sponsors there's one for today's episode
and that is brilliant during the winter
break i decided to brush up on the
fundamentals of information theory which
is what constructor theory is heavily
based in and i'd like to do an episode
on that so i took brilliant's course on
knowledge and uncertainty and random
variables and after taking that course i
could finally see why entropy is defined
the way it is why the formula for it is
extremely natural there are plenty of
courses you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the internal symmetries of
the standard model is u1 cross s2 cross
su 3 those are league groups visit
brilliant.org toe to get 20 off the
annual subscription i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons just keep
pursuing until you've accomplished at
least four and i think you'll be greatly
surprised at the ease at which you can
now comprehend subjects you previously
had a difficult time grocking and now on
to today's episode which is one that i'm
extremely lucky to be able to present to
you all you'll be able to see the mutual
respect that the guests have for one
another we start off actually by asking
what is it that you respect about each
other's work enjoy this theo locution
between carl fristen michael levin and
chris fields i've been extremely excited
about this
so professor what do you find unique
about carl's and chris's work and what
is it that you respect about them
well what a great question i think all
discussions should uh should should
start with that question um uh there's a
lot i mean i think i think uh the most
basic thing i can say is this that i'm
i'm often asked by by uh conference
organizers and students as far as who
who they should follow yeah who's whose
work they should um keep track of and
and so i keep lists and uh and and carl
and chris are at the very top of two
specific lists for me and i'm just
always amazed about this is that the
first the first is that um both of them
are experts in at least three different
fields but probably more so so so they
have the ability to kind of merge really
deep um understanding of different
fields i mean there's many people that
are experts in one thing
but i'm just i'm just always incredibly
impressed that's how they uh both of
them can we weave together a really deep
knowledge from from from diverse
disciplines and and and that leads to
the kind of the second thing that that
i'm really inspired by which is just the
kind of the sheer density of new ideas
you know it's hard enough to push things
in one just kind of one known direction
and do science and so on but both both
chris and carl's work um consistently
make me think in new ways uh give me
ideas i've never never thought of before
it's just just just amazing so yeah so
i'm super excited to be able to work
with both of them and to have this
discussion
great
chris same question but toward michael
and carl
uh well i can say that
one thing i certainly
admire
is that
uh
michael and carl are both
top-level biologists who are interested
in theory
and and deeply involved in theory
and have a deep understanding
of
uh theory
and
uh
something that i enormously admire
is that both of them
have that interest
and yet are deeply engaged in practical
applications
uh
carl and mental health and
mike and regenerative biology
and that's
a rare combination
carl what is it that you find unique
about michael's and chris's work and
what do you particularly respect about
them as people perhaps
i deliberately haven't rehearsed an
answer so what i say comes from the
heart
um
so with mike um
i first met him vicariously through a
friend giovanni pizzulo
and
didn't really know very much about his
work until i visited his website and
then i realized how influential and
important he was and then i recognized
all the little bulletins you get on
social media and emails i started to
recognize his name and realize that he
was you know he was quite a mover and
shaker out there
what i like about both of them they both
think really really fast and they both
think out of the box um
so i think what characterizes
both of their thinking really is just to
ask what is a thing in and of itself
without making any prior assumptions and
then putting it back together
from basic principles and coming up with
some sometimes counter-intuitive um
conclusions and but for me
almost uh universally exactly the same
counter-intuitive conclusions i've come
to after about 10 years of thinking
about a particular problem but never
dare tell anybody but they do they write
it down very eloquently and
they're very very productive
chris i've known for less long and i've
met him via mike um and
in addition to that in the same way that
many people i meet have physics envy and
i've got quantum envy uh for about chris
yeah he just seems to know so much
and think about the world in a way which
i don't have that sort of fluency in but
it sounds really really useful and and
quite correct so i'm hoping if i hang
around long enough some of it will rub
off on me
should be able to use the words without
sounding like an idiot
what would be an example of this
out-of-the-box thinking you mentioned
thinking about what is a thing in and of
itself
what else
there are numerous examples um the first
thing that just came to mind was just
putting together
fundamental questions about
self-organization if you were varela uh
you know so autophagus self-assembly
self-construction if you're a chemist it
would be self-assembly if you're a
theoretical biologist
um you will be wondering about why on
earth is it that um all multicellular
organisms form
because there's a deep paradox there yep
if it is the case that i have to have a
surface as a little organ
then some of myself have cells have to
stop replicating and yet that is in
direct contradiction to the principles
of natural selection i'm going to turn
off my reproductive capacity my adaptive
fitness so defined in a theoretical
context so i just really sit down
grasping the nettle i'm thinking about
well these things exist
what principles could possibly explain
the paradoxes were looked at from sort
of the unilateral the monothematic view
of natural selection for example or the
monothematic view of self-organization
in physics so thinking out of the box
literally in this instance um entails
being able to take multiple perspectives
on a particular problem and seeing the
contradictions and seeing how they can
be resolved now they'll be one of many
examples uh look there was a paper like
i'm afraid i can't remember the specific
one perhaps mike and chris will be able
to enlighten me but there was one
paper
written i i think about a year or two
ago where they actually listed i think
there were 15 basic conclusions about
the the fundaments and the and the
the nature of self-organization and self
as distinct from other uh in any system
and you know this listing uh
15 really interesting points and
predictions all of which either um i'm
sure will be formally demonstrably
analytically um
true uh or
at least yield or be amenable to a
mathematical analysis um or would be
empirically verifiable um over the next
few years
what was that
there was a paper in neuroscience of
consciousness
of
arguing for
a
an approach to consciousness that
spanned phylogeny
and we were very interested in that
paper
specifically to look at
bacteria and single cells
and um
facultative multicellular such as
microbial biofilms
and ask
what do these systems know about the
world how did they see the world
uh
how does it how does e coli perceive the
world for example
and
we suggested that
the the answer is in in terms of of the
sorts of things that we call taste and
viscosity
but that
experiences of taste and viscosity are
perfectly good kinds of experiences
and that if we think about
how
these kinds of systems
deal with their worlds
and solve problems within their worlds
that that would give us a more
unified understanding of what it meant
to be
a system that was aware
and so you're trying to
use e coli as a
means of understanding yourself or
humans by the way is this a project do
you feel like your undertaking is an
attempt for you to understand yourself
or you're trying to understand humans
like i'm wondering is this more
philanthropic or it's selfish and then
it bleeds into the philanthropic
well i i actually also want to
understand e coli
and b we have
we don't have a great understanding of
of the lives of other organisms
professor levin
what puzzle do you find most important
what do you think about on a semi daily
basis or even perhaps multiple times a
day and then we'll go around the table
here with chris fields and carl fursten
next and then it's essentially me taking
a backseat and allowing you all to free
flow just for the audience to know i
know you all know this template already
yeah um so so the thing i think about
many times a day has to do with the
scaling of cognition so i want to
understand to two two major things one
is how it is that uh some collection of
competent uh parts comes together to
form a
an emergent self with preferences goals
memories
cognitive capacities that belong to it
but not to the individual parts so i
want to understand how that how that
emerges how the goals of uh you know
sort of humble um
a simple uh simple kinds of systems
scale up into much more grandiose goals
that we see in during during development
during behavior uh you know during uh
culture and and so on and and i'm also
very interested in uh the sort of the
left side of that spectrum where does it
begin you know is there really a zero on
the spectrum i think that uh all of us
we here would agree that there is a
spectrum for these things it's not a set
of binary categories but what happens at
the very left side of the spectrum and
so one of the first questions you know
when we get to that that um that i'd
written down to ask both chris and
carlos to sort of comment on
what does the what does the venn diagram
look like of of the set of things that
are alive versus the set of things that
are cognitive yeah how do those two
categories relate to each other until
they overlap is one a subset of the
other and what really happens at the
very beginning you know like
can we can we develop a kind of um
which which i think i think both of them
have been working on a kind of basically
a kind of pan psychism that doesn't
doesn't sort of paint on new cognitive
mysteries on top of physics that works
perfectly well but instead to try and to
try to view physics from the bottom up
as having already a useful cognitive
lens on it and how does that help us to
build up cognition so that's that's
something that i think about every day
chris
um
i i thought
every day or almost every day for a long
time
about
why
we
humans
see objects embedded in space-time
so why do we see things
that we treat as independent of each
other
and why do we
see them operate on them interact with
them
think about them
as
embedded in this coordinate system that
we call space
and
uh equally important
why do we see them as maintaining
their identities as things
over this other coordinate that we call
time
carl
um
i have to confess i spend recurrently
most of my time thinking about me um but
in an academic sense you know how do i
work
so
it's a curious mixture of
introspection and trying to understand
why i can introspect uh in from the
perspective or through the lens of a
physicist so i i spend most of my time
dissembling preconceptions the gifts
that uh our sentience has given us um
and try to
reassemble them in relation to
physics density dynamics uh you know
that that has to be articulated in terms
of the kind of maths that a physicist
would use which would be effectively
differential equations and the calculus
of variations
and having done that there are so many
um
there are sufficient number of moving
parts but not that many uh but the
combinatorics then lead you to the
the kinds of questions that mike was was
talking about so you know what different
ways could this um
physics of sentience
um
be manifest what possible ways could it
be manifest and how does that address
the distinction between um things
particles creatures um that would show
the kind of sense-making and to my mind
an important aspect is planning that
this would disambiguate them from other
natural kinds or particular kinds that
don't have that kind of facility and
what underwrites that um
so that's what i spend most of my time
doing i have to say in conversation both
with
mike and chris and other people um
there you can easily get distracted um
in in a rightful way um
by
um thinking about that mechanics in uh
exactly what chris was talking to which
is a scale-free way but in my rhetoric
that scale freeness speaks more to the
coupling between different scales that
mike was alluding to
so how does
this um mechanics this physics of
sentience which which i understand
largely in terms of probability theory
and
effectively bayesian um probability
theory
so what you have is a bayesian mechanics
how does that basic mechanics apply at
one scale and another scale and then of
course the big questions is how did the
two scales couple to each other so that
that that for me is something that i i
find myself increasingly pressed upon
largely through conversations and
collaborations um
that does mean that i spend a lot of my
time thinking about that and you're
writing demos or mathematical equations
trying to try to get to the um
the uh the underpinnings of it
mike i see you nodding so what is it
about what carl said i'm sorry okay
professor 11 i apologize and what is it
that
what is it that professor fristen said
that has you
feeling like you agree with it
well as as usual i mean he said it
perfectly i couldn't i couldn't say it
better myself i think that's uh that's
that's exactly the kind of um
uh research agenda that i'm interested
in i mean that's that really is the kind
of a very good um description of what i
think we're all looking for in a certain
sense
is there a difference between cognition
and
consciousness
is one distinct is there overlap
is someone a subset
i i actually can't conceive of
cognition without
consciousness
which i
i prefer to call awareness
not just to be perverse but because in
many cases
consciousness is
used in a way that implicitly means
self-consciousness
whereas awareness is often used in a way
that does not make that implication
and
it's i i find it difficult to conceive
of cognition without any kind of
awareness at all
so so so could i just so i'll ask a
question then based on what what chris
just said and then what when you know
and what carl has to say about it so so
what do you think about the so-called
hard problem is there in fact a hard
problem at all
i would um
i would take andy clark's view on this
uh
who has worked closely with david
chalmers
i i i don't think so no i i i don't
think that the hard problem in and of
itself is um
is the um
interesting um focus of inquiry
i think the um the move that i see in
philosophy um has been to the meta
problem or the meta hard problem which
is
um as andy clark puts it quite
succinctly is why do we spend so much
time puzzling about why we are aware
so
just asking that question
um
speaks to i think the nature of the
heart problem which is a sort of very
much a second order a meta um a metric
capability that we can
make sense of our own sense-making and
we um associate that with selfhood so
one has to ask the question what kinds
of systems
again i think particles or creatures
would have the capacity
to represent selfhood and furthermore
represent
the counterfactuals
that would enable you to ask the
question why am i conscious that
immediately just logically presupposes
that there is an alternative hypothesis
some other counterfactual that i'm not
conscious
so imagine now you're talking to
a creature you're talking to me that has
this capacity to imagine
counterfactuals that cannot exist
so that's a remarkable capacity to have
you know um from my point of view a sort
of internal world moral regenerative
model
where counterfactuals can exist is quite
remarkable i i don't imagine that a
thermostat or a virus or
an e coli
will have a sufficiently sophisticated
set of you know
electrochemical uh dynamics or kinetics
that would enable them to physically
represent
counterfactuals of this sort and i could
go on um
the the usual line of argument is why do
we have models why do we have the
capacity to represent counterfactuals um
the you end up with saying yes you have
to have them
just if you
[Music]
contemplate
things at plan so things plan
they have to have
um an ability to simulate the future
that because they have to simulate or
represent at some elemental level the
consequences of their action upon the
world
and if they have now the capacity to
represent
something that has not yet happened
namely in the future then they now have
the capacity to represent counter
factual outcomes so i think
the meta hard problem
inherits simply because we have a
sufficiently
temporally deep
generative model
that can represent the consequences of
our actions and of course using the word
our
implies
some kind of elemental agency and some
kind of self-worth because it's only me
that's doing the acting and the
consequences of my action not your
action uh so so
in in that sense i think that the hard
problem um
sort of pales into into insignificance
in relation to the the meta problem of
why it is that we have philosophers
can i pursue that just a little bit
i think you raise an extraordinarily
interesting point here carl
and so
i want to ask you
from a phylogenetic perspective
do you think that
organisms
that can plan
necessarily
are able to represent multiple
counterfactuals
so let's give an example
of suppose you're a cheetah chasing a
gazelle
you're planning your moves
while looking at the gazelle's moves
and your objective is success
do you think that the cheetah worries
about the other counterfactual condition
where the gazelle isn't caught
or does it just represent this one
counterfactual condition that is in a
sense the goal state
i think that's an excellent question i
personally think that
and when i answer these questions i
think how would i simulate this how
would i put a cheater in silico
and
integrate
according to the differential equations
that must be present under certain
assumptions um and my guess is that the
cheetah chasing the gazelle would as you
say just be pursuing a path of least
action and it would not have an explicit
representation of alternative paths so
it would be responding in the moment in
a reflexive habitual way so that's a
really important question because if we
don't have or all of our behavior
is just a manifestation of pursuing
those paths of least resistance or
mathematically those you know paths of
space reaction
um then there is no counterfactual to
select from and there is no notion of
planning in the sense of i am going to
do this as opposed to that but that
doesn't mean to say biological organisms
um don't have the capacity to
plan multiple futures and i'll just give
you one real simple example of um
your our brains and i would imagine even
the brains of reptiles to a certain
extent um
being able to plan multiple um
actions in the future and that's in eye
movements
so if i just take one of the simplest
problems in terms of planning or perhaps
not the simplest but one of the um
the the the problems of planning that
have to be resolved within um
you know several hundred milliseconds
given that we have to choose where to
look every 250 milliseconds in order to
gather the right kind of information to
make you know to construct the scene in
which we are situated and coming back to
your preoccupation chris your you know
how on earth do we then explain these
sparse
um
uh psychotic samples
within some frame of reference and
space-time sort of phrase how do we you
know
sense make with reference to some
constructs such as space and time but
the point i'm making here
is the anatomy of um
many uh
brains many phenotypes does have the
capacity to represent the consequences
of looking everywhere at the same time
at once before they have looked so these
are sort of
sometimes referred to as salience maps
and we know that
there are good candidates for these
salience maps for example the deep
layers of the superior colliculus and
what could have argue um possibly some
anatomy of the pulvina so if you look at
the um if you like the neuronal encoding
of the salience of where the salience of
the next place to look
what's going to grab my attention
and make that be manifest overtly with
an eye movement to go look over there
then there you can interpret i think the
anatomy the oculomotor system and
especially the um
that which underlies uh circadian
control synthetic eye movements as
entertaining
a whole range possibly millions of
potential um
plans of action and the consequences
and then the brain literally selects the
one that's most likely
which you can simulate by doing bump
attractors on these sort of salience
maps or representations of the the
salience of the epistemic affordance or
the expected information again if i
looked over here and over here and over
here looked over here you select that
your eyes jump over there and off you go
again so i think it's a great question
and in a sense speaks i think to a
certain extent to what mike was alluding
to before that there are certain
setups or a certain sort of neuronal
electrochemical um
infrastructures
out there
that can be read as just pursuing
passively such action in a reflexive way
and there are others that may have this
um richer structure this deeper
structure that could be uh support the
you know the the the active sentence and
the sort of what i i'm reading now is
cognition if cognition entails planning
uh then i certainly think there has to
be an act of selection in play here um
selection what does that mean from
something from what well multiple
alternatives and then we come back to
the central notion of this this counter
factual
mike is that what you had in mind in
terms of breaking this sort of uh pan
psychism uh sort of trap you know the
different kinds of
self-organization
yeah i mean that's certainly certainly
related you know uh the thing the the
thing that i and and so i agree with
chris's
kind of gut feeling on this i find it
very difficult to imagine cognition
without some sort of awareness or or
simple consciousness however what what
strikes me as
different than real about the hard
problem is that unlike all the quote
unquote easy problems and maybe unlike
the meta hard problem
we kind of know the format or the shape
of answers to those questions right
they're either they're numbers or their
equations or their lists of capacities
you know we we know what what a proper
answer would look like and yet i find it
very hard to imagine if we if somebody
claimed to have a
a good theory of consciousness and i
were to ask them okay well what is the
prediction of your theory in this
particular case i don't know what the
format of the answer looks like because
numbers and the typical things we get
don't do the trick they you know they're
sort of third person descriptions and so
so is the answer does the answer come in
the form of a poem is it art is it you
know something you have to literally
plug yourself into to then have that
experience like what's the i i find it
different because i don't know what if
we had a true a correct theory i don't
know what that theory would output you
know unlike for all these other theories
where at least we have some idea of what
the output looks like
well that's a better answer to the hard
problem then that's very good
before
i'm sure the answer is quantum physics
and that's that's what it's going to
look like if we could if we could
understand it the answer would be in
quantum physics
chris do you agree
well i i'd like to to back up a little
bit
uh
and in a sense
play off what carl was just saying about
alternatives and the role of
alternatives in the heart problem
i mean chalmers drives his arguments
about the hard problem with
the alternative of unconsciousness
and
this alternative
makes
great sense
against the background of a particular
set of assumptions about
physics
uh
which is
the assumption that
nothing is going on cognitively in the
physical world that there's that there's
no reason to
talk about
uh experience or awareness or anything
like that
when we're talking about
rocks or billiard balls or planets or
electrons or
anything else
and
in that case
there is this
cut
that is
not really a cut in scale
of
spatial scale or temporal scale
but is in a sense a cut in some measure
of complexity
that suggests that
below some
cut point which may be a bright line and
maybe a fuzzy area who knows
there's the possibility
or below some cut point there's there's
no awareness at all none
zero
and above that cut point there's some
possibility of awareness
and in that case one's forced to say how
what what could be added
by complexity other than complexity
to produce awareness
and it's that intuition i believe that
drives the hard problem
do you mind explaining that a bit more
what can be added by complexity that's
not complexity or the sentence
well
um yeah
and one way to put it is
complexity
as complexity increases some magic has
to happen
and
you suddenly get awareness
and
it's not clear quite how much complexity
one has to add
but as soon as one reaches the the right
amount then
uh
out of the blue you've got awareness
whereas without crossing that threshold
you you had no awareness whatsoever
so there's a zero point and the zero
points somewhere on the scale of
complexity
and it's nowhere near the bottom
so i think one can i can i think one can
view a lot of research on
consciousness
as a way to escape that
argument
so
i'll
consider integrated information theory
oh
in integrated information theory the
criterion for
consciousness or awareness
is actually very simple you you need to
have an internal feedback loop
and if you've got an internal feedback
loop you're at least a candidate for
being aware
as long as you're not embedded in
something bigger that has bigger
internal feedback loops
and
if one
thinks about
the work of peter strawson for example
from a philosophical perspective
his arguments toward
pansysm
are all arguments of the form
there's no way to draw the lie
in the
scale of complexity
and get a place where
magic basically plausibly happens
so
i think i think chalmers did a real
service in in
posing the problem in that way because
it forced us to think about this idea of
magic or you could call it emergence if
you wanted to
of something completely new that was
awareness
now i i do agree with carl that
quantum theory can help us
dispel the problem
uh by by being in effect a theory that's
about awareness
but we can we can get to that farther
down the road
do you have any reason to believe that
we're embedded in something larger you
mentioned in
iit there's the feedback loop that is
necessary for consciousness and you said
that
one is conscious as long as one is not
embedded in something else that's
of which that is conscious like there's
a larger feedback loop there
do you see there being some larger
feedback loop some people say the
universe itself is conscious or that
societies can act as some larger level
consciousness
like with each of us acting as neurons
in some sense
well i would certainly wouldn't want to
rule that view out a priori
i mean it's it's obvious that we're
embedded in much bigger systems
and
i think we understand
essentially nothing about the cognitive
capacities of those systems
yeah
michael
yeah yeah i think i think that's a
really important question and i i think
a lot about the perspective of let's say
you know if you were a neural network or
something like this being trained and so
on what would the perspective of a sub
component of that be what you know let's
say if you had the capacity as a neuron
to sort of look around and ask yourself
you know do i do i live in a cold
mechanical universe that doesn't care
what happens or uh is there some some
sort of uh agency in my environment that
you know am i when i'm as a piece of
that network am i am i learning from my
environment or am i being trained right
because when you're being trained right
the real question is like how many how
many um agents are there in that
interaction is it just you learning as
you will you're the boss and you're sort
of learning whatever from your
environment or are you actually being
trained because the environment is an
agent with an agenda that is training
you for some particular purpose right
and so so this question of uh how would
you know so so you look around and you
see you say to yourself well
if you're a piece of this of this
network and it's being trained for some
image image recognition task you know
you you would be i think wrong to come
to the conclusion that you live in a in
a mechanical universe you would you
should come to the conclusion that it's
actually it's clearly rewarding you and
punishing you for for specific things
it's not neutral with respect to what
you do and for some reason it really
likes it when you find you know you find
um pictures of dog eyes or something
like this and you have no idea that what
what it does is recognize dog faces out
of you know all the other all the other
inputs so
no doubt there's some kind of gerdelian
limit to to be able to actually
understand what the larger system is
doing but i wonder if we can even have
some evidence that uh just just for the
fact that yes there is a greater you
know sort of a agential dynamic going on
in which i'm caught up even if you're
not able to you know sort of comprehend
what that's going to what that's going
to be i i don't know i don't know what
that's going to look like but i think
it's pretty important and i think as
chris said we really don't have a very
good science at all of
trying to predict or control
the cognitive capacities of systems made
up of parts so so we can know many
things about parts cells robotics or
whatever and we routinely make these
larger systems have then and then get
surprised about what it does or doesn't
do or what what what the goals are going
to be what goals is it capable of
pursuing what preferences does it have
this is probably an existential level um
job for for society is to get a good
science of that of that going
you have done that there haven't you
well we've started anyway
i mean you couldn't i i would go film
that
i think i think your work would
represent
a substantive and established um
formal framework to address exactly
those issues um
and you can see your embryonic versions
arising in many different fields i just
came back from a meeting
of economists and financiers and they
are trying to make the move from
behavioral economics to cognitive
economics and they were exactly
addressing these kinds of issues you're
understanding
the
um
the notion of distributed cognition in a
market um so you know and ultimately
that they cannot they'll come knocking
at your door i can see that i can see
exactly the
sequence of people um you know searching
around for people to talk about um
illuminating
that realization that the i mean it
comes back to what we were talking about
before where you've started and you know
i was picking up on the um
on the the link between different scales
of self-organization where every scale
has you know complies with the same
principles but how does that
contextualize and i think one really
interesting
example of that um
is to think about an individual in an
ensemble or a society and just to
wrestle the argument back to pick up on
something that chris was saying about
you know
you know if if there is a bright line
between
the kind of
mechanics that would qualify
as
conscious in the sense of being
self-aware and i'm distinguishing that
from the kind of consciousness that
would just entail qualitative experience
you know a loss of phenomenal uh
transparency so i'm talking about now
self-awareness is you know one of one of
the bright lines that may be very blurry
blurry and vague but certainly one which
is induced by uh the hard problem
you know just asking a simple question
your what kind of explanation for my
world whether i'm a single neuron or a
single person
and would
enable me or justify
the notion that i am myself
and the obvious answer is
when i have to disambiguate between the
consequences of my action and your
action if you are very similar to me
so if i
you know managed to survive in on an
alien planet
where there are no structures like like
me that could cause the same sense to
consequences
then there would be no problem inferring
did i cause that or did you cause that
so just having um the existence of a
population of con specifics in some sort
of formal structural sense
suddenly induces the inference problem
did you cause that do i cause that and
of course that naturally calls for
generative models or internal dynamics
representations on the inside
um
that entertain the hypothesis on the
notion that that's me
as opposed to not me so you get for free
in and only in this context where you've
put lots of these particles together
like you know the
if you like the license or the
motivation to have a hypothesis um you
know a representation of selfhood um
that you know from the statisticians
point of view
is exactly
the justification for the increased
complexity that chris was talking about
so i was listening to that really
interesting sort of uh um sort of
nod to iit and all it brings to the
table in terms of this sort of you know
commitment to some threshold crossing or
trans traversing a cut
with increasing complexity but why i
mean one simple answer is that um
you know if you ask a statistician what
is complexity and they'll tell you well
um it's basically the degrees of freedom
you're using up to explain some sensory
data
um you could articulate it as a kl or
relative entry between a posterior prior
if you're a bayesian but in essence it's
just the degrees of freedom
you're um using in order to accurately
explain these data
so mathematically the evidence is equal
to the accuracy minus the complexity so
why would you need what why why is that
useful well an increase in complexity
license
is only licensed by an increase in the
accuracy so the simple argument would go
and if i am
obliged to model and predict and explain
a world
and that is constituted by other things
like me
then the accuracy of my predictions will
be greatly enhanced if i have a
representation of me as distinct from
you
and if that entails an increase in the
degrees of freedom namely adding in this
extra kind of a hypothesis and
everything that it entails
then
i'm going to have a greater complexity
but it's a complexity that is more than
paid for by the uh by the increase
increase in the accuracy
and i you know
just coming back to you know my original
point um
yeah i think a lot of the work um that
you've done at the cellular level
um
would be very gracefully translated to
the societal level and to things like
economics and to
echo niche construction and in ethology
and i know chris is probably wanting to
say this
but language has one way of facilitating
that notion that ability to
um to efficiently with minimum
complexity in this instance um
do this distributed cognition so i'm
both trained being trained and learning
at the same time and we're doing it
together to invent some kind of
generalized synchrony
so i mentioned language for chris there
the font hope he wants to pick that one
up
oh
well well again what i'd actually like
to do is back up a little bit
and uh put some of what you just said
into
very simple active inference language
if if i see something happening
on my markov blanket on my interface
with the world
then i always have the question
did i do that or did the world do that
where the world means everything outside
me
and
in a sense
the answer is always the world did it so
the question becomes
did the world do that in response to
something i did to it
or did it just do it
not not in consequence of any of my
actions
and so one gets immediately to this kind
of babbling scenario that we've talked
about many times
in which
an infant or a robot or some system
is trying to figure out
by
measuring correlations
whether
the world's inputs to it have anything
to do with its inputs to the world
and
just
asking that question
requires enormous
representative capacity
because one has to represent one's
actions
and represent them pretty well in time
and one has to
have a good memory
to represent enough actions to get any
kind of statistical support for drawing
an inference about correlation
and
that memory has to
be represented as a memory
uh not just part of one's own current
input
so i think this
question that you
posed
is really the key question faced by any
agent at all
that's trying to get a model off the
ground
which
which in a sense gets back to the
question that mike asked early early on
about how does this all start
uh
maybe it starts with babbling
in very simple systems
you know i i was thinking recently uh
this this this whole issue of how many
agents are there and where is the border
between the agent and the world and how
do you self-model that border is is a
fascinating topic and there's a there's
an amazing um
developmental model for this which is
which is that you know we often talk
about one embryo and the embryo does
this in the embryo does that but
actually what happens at the beginning
let's say for example an amniote embryos
is that there's a there's a flat blasted
disc which has just a few cell layers
thick so it's kind of think of it like a
like a frisbee and it just has a few
cell layers
and normally what has to happen is that
one point in this in this disc breaks
symmetry and then organizes the primary
axis of the first embryo and basically
tells all the other cells
don't do it because because i'm doing it
and that's how you end up with one
embryo now that process is very easily
perturbed and and i many people have
done it i used to do it in my in my
graduate work and what you can do is if
you perturb that process that initial
blasto disc that undifferentiated sort
of pool of of cells which are these sort
of proto
uh low-level proto-proto-agents that
pool can break up into not one embryo
but actually multiple and so you can
have so i did this in in bird embryos
and you could have twins and chicken and
duck and things like this you can have
in humans humans have exactly the same
structure
you can get them head to head you can
have to get them side by side you can
get all sorts of geometries you can get
triplets you can get multiple
individuals awry emerging by different
partitions of this of this
really kind of
medium this particular medium where
where you have a bunch of cells and you
don't know ahead of time how many
individuals at the level of how many
larger individuals so embryos are going
to arise from this medium because the
the dynamics by which in that's you know
local activation and long-range
inhibition and things like that the the
dynamics that break up that that
undifferentiated ocean of of potential
selves into one two or three or more
selves is actually um it's very dynamic
it can it can go different ways
and then you get interesting interesting
things like this so for example you
might know that human conjoined twins
that are you know sort of stuck together
side to side one of the twins often has
left right asymmetry defects and it's
because when you have two twins side by
side the cells in the middle both twins
can't quite agree on who they belong to
are they the right side of this twin or
are they the left side of that twin and
both twins think they belong to them but
in fact they're overlapping they're the
same cells and so one side will have
correct left and right the other guy the
other side will have like two rights for
example right and this ends up this ends
up giving one of the twins laterality
defects with respect to heart and gut
patterning and so so their models each
twins as as the collective of cells
tries to compute uh things like which
which
where things are and what's left and
what's right and so on their models can
disagree with each other they can they
can draw the boundary between self and
world in different ways and you can have
these sort of disputes over certain
areas as to where who they actually
belong to
and and so so i'm just i'm just
incredibly interested in this in this
process of of emerging of
individualization so to speak out of
this like ocean of of potentiality these
cells you know 50 000 cells and some
number of individuals at the um at the
embryo level will be formed and each of
them will have specific goals in
morphospace each of them will try to
achieve very specific morphologies uh
and uh and they've and then you don't
know ahead of time how many there were
going to be you know
carl what occurs to you when you hear
that
um
ambiguity um again sort of um
just thinking about the imperatives for
self-organization
so
when i hear that was a fascinating story
um and don't let me forget we ought to
explain to the viewers what babbling
means just in this context as well
because that's quite illuminating
perhaps we can i'm not sure that the
cells do do motor babbling um but they
certainly resolve um the same kind of
problem um so my um chris correct me if
i'm wrong but by babbling all we mean is
that when you're
first born into any universe you've got
to
um
work out
or test the hypothesis that i cause that
or the world caused that and so you
don't know you don't have a self model
you don't you know
whether this is sort of
a declarative model completely so
personal just
hardwired into the um the synaptic
efficacy and connectivity of your brain
so the first thing you have to do is
just to work out what you can control
and what you can't control
and the idea is that you you
engage in
what i would call epistemic or respond
to epistemic affordances or epistemic
plans that reveal knowledge they resolve
uncertainty and in this instance it's
the uncertainty about whether
i was the cause of this rattle rattling
so if you imagine um motor babbling
as manifest in a little baby
rattling its rattle
generating both the sensations
from the muscles and the skin but also
the visual
and the auditory sensations all co-occur
providing definitive evidence that
there's something special about
this process and this event
that um
that provides the basis for the
hypothesis there's a unitary cause
there's a unitary cause which is me
shaking the rattle but of course it may
take several months if not years to
actually get there to actually realize
that causes me so what can you imagine
sort of you know robots learning about
the uh the manipulator that they can
articulate all the the way in which they
can move around and you know um
for ambulate um but i think the idea
bring it back to sort of where the self
had come from um
it would um
rest upon
the testing the hypothesis which has to
be physically represented with a deep
more complex genetic model and sense
making
that in fact it's me that's actually
caused this single cause of all these
proprioceptive
motor sensations visual sensations
auditory sensations um and that would be
especially prescient when you're
starting to realize that some of these
causes which you thought were you
of the sort associated with nurturing
and suckling um were actually due to mum
and we come back to this argument to to
actually have a good hypothesis which
explains why i am not in charge of mum
because she is now not always responding
to me when i cry
yeah to have to explain that i have to
now develop a hypothesis yes it was me
causing all of this
um but sometimes there's something else
else out there that's not me but very
much like me and that's mum and then you
can see how there would be a pressure
in terms of you know finding the best
explanations for your sensations to to
have that so if you take that notion now
think of the same problem uh from the
point of view of a cell
um you know what are the impaired or a
bunch of cells that have to work
together or will ultimately form a uh an
embryo
via this process of symmetry breaking
you you know you have to ask what are
the underlying imperatives how how could
it be any other way um and of course it
could be more like i said it could be
lots of ways but
the ways the ways in which it goes wrong
um which would be another way of saying
um those rare occasions or the the ways
that it doesn't happen in
consequence of their rarity um involve
this ambiguity again
literally in this in the context of some
cells not knowing whether they're
belonging to one twin or or another twin
from the from the cell's perspective
um
so um i was just thinking about the
nature of ambiguity and of course you
know it is exactly the same
um
one can account
for
the
simple observation that
self-organization
does not tolerate ambiguity does not
tolerate uncertainty it's only um
manifest in the context of
accurate and
well-evidenced definitive uh exchanges
so come back to chris's notion of your
sense making
projecting onto my markov blanket or my
holographic screen from the point of
view of the quantum formulation
that i need to resolve all the
uncertainty uh
as much uncertainty as i can but put
that another way
um as in a more slightly more
deflationary way
stuff which we see the way the universe
seems to work
is um
can be described as
um realizing processes that minimize
this this kind of uncertainty and
ambiguity and simply maximize the mutual
predictability of what's being projected
or impressed upon my surface on my
holographic screen or my markov blanket
uh so i you know that's what i was that
was going through my mind i thought it
was a beautiful example of of you know
when it goes wrong the the the the the
the
uncertainty in ambiguity you're in the
game and uh and that tells you something
quite fundamental about when it goes
right and when it goes right it's just
basically um a statement of what exists
and what you know what what perseveres
over time chris did you have anything to
say to add to that
well i would be interested to uh
to see how actually
how
mike responds to
that
uh
discourse with respect to the example of
this embryonic sheet where
the cells are each trying to figure out
what they're supposed to do
uh
and
there's they're still
uh
they still certainly believe that they
should be reproducing so they they
definitely do that and they signal to
each other
but somehow their
the collective effect of all of that
signaling to each other
is to organize different roles for them
for each for themselves
so how does the symmetry breaking occur
yeah so so that's that's really
interesting so as i was hearing um carl
talk about this i realized a couple of
things that um first of all uh as we
were saying before feedback loops are
absolutely central to this process
because the easiest way to prevent any
of this from happening and to end up
with a uh uh um kind of a mono um you
know sort of uh i you know a very a
featureless sheet where there are no
embryos is to block that is to block the
positive feedback loop that yeah so so
that long that that short range
inhibition long range activation that
says to one cell i'm going to now be the
organizer i'm going to make this axis
everybody else don't do it you those are
both feedback loops and so if you break
those feedback loops you get nothing so
so the feedback loops are right at the
beginning of this process and and the
other thing that that i thought was
really interesting that carl just said
is about the cells babbling so what i
think
it's a really good name for what we see
when you take a cell and you put it out
into a dish
what you'll see you'll and in fact in
any in any new environment you will see
two things that i think are probably
babbling in different spaces one is that
in physical space you will see that it's
incredibly active it's constantly
putting out and pulling back these these
um
kind of extensions so these cytoplasmic
extensions that have all kinds of
sensors on them they're not just sitting
the cell is never just sitting there
waiting for something to happen it's
constantly probing its environment it's
incredibly active i'm sure it's taking
all kinds of energy costs to do all this
um there are videos of it that are just
remarkable on online and you know we see
them every day the other the other
babbling takes place in transcriptional
space so gene expression is also never
just sort of still and this is you know
these are the genes that are expressed
and i'm just gonna sit here and do that
all the genes are constantly going up
and down within specific ranges as it
sort of wiggles in this transcriptional
space and i think both and probably
physiologically metabolically i bet this
is going on in all these other spaces
and i think babbling is an excellent uh
framework for for understanding what
it's actually doing it's actually taking
these little actions looking for
evidence of specific things that it can
then make use of to start to draw you
know to draw boundaries and and as chris
as chris was saying i think what happens
is that
in this blastoderm you get uh
what what what will happen is that once
once that that individuation starts
where there's a specific cell that
starts to go down this road of uh being
the organizer of this new
larger collective it immediately begins
to distort the action space for all the
nearby cells it starts putting out all
kinds of signals you know reward signals
and and physical forces and all these
other things that now
are going to bend the uh the option for
all the other cells and the best example
of that we have are these xenobots where
these things are just made of embryonic
skin cells and if you look at a standard
old embryo you get this idea that well
what do skin cells want to do they want
to be a passive two-dimensional layer on
the outside of the animal they do
nothing except sit there keep out the
bacteria you know nice and a boring
two-dimensional life but what you find
out is that that's only true because the
other cells are basically bullying them
into it left to their own devices with
the in the absence of these instructive
interactions with the rest of the embryo
what they what the skin cells actually
want to do is get together into a
three-dimensional uh kind of ball like
architecture they are self-motile that
you know they'll run around and move and
do very have various behaviors including
make copies of themselves if provided
with materials and so that is completely
um
kind of obscured by standard development
where what you're seeing actually is is
cells in a space that was really
deformed by by all their neighbors right
and that's you know that kind of process
that that that starts to devel you know
make them make those distinctions where
the embryo
the embryo can tell what part uh what
parts are inside and what parts are
supposedly outside of itself and that
that gets reinforced by all these early
activities
carl or chris do you want to jump in on
that i think i think we've been
describing cyclists that says basically
that it's curiosity all the way down
every system is trying to figure out
what's going on i was struck with that
with this image of the little cells
putting out fingers you know this is
expiration your sort of true blue
exploration and mathematically it's
simply as it says it's um
what
what
artificial intelligence um research
aspires to which is artificial curiosity
you know
going out there getting the right kind
of data
that's going to maximally resolve your
uncertainty and paint the way the way
forward and of course it's
intimately related to planning
in the sense you have to um
realize that palpation you know whether
it's a little cell palpating whether
it's failure or podia or um whether it's
me palpating my visual world i move my
eyes around or whether it's the
little baby babbling and palpating it's
cot this this this this palpation
has to be planned
it could be planned in the sense of the
gazelle sorry because it's not the
gazelle the cheetah chasing the gazelle
so it doesn't have to be very
sophisticated cognitive conscious
planning but certainly has to has to be
planned it has to have this sort of
curious behavior um i mean it you know
it strikes me that that is such a
fundamental um aspect
that i think would qualify
behaviors
that have that aspect as cognitive in
some sense and it's so fundamental
because of course it's it's just an
expression
of
dynamics that apply
to
um action upon the world
um
that
underwrite
everything that we do as certainly as
scientists and one could imagine as as
human beings but certainly as scientists
you know that the maths of curiosity was
was actually worked out um by dennis
lindley in the 1950s
um in terms of expected information gain
and then reintroduced by people like
david mckay in the context of active
learning so bringing this active notion
that you can learn by actively acquiring
the right kind of data that optimizes
that kind of learning
and it became known as
the principles of optimum bayesian
experimental design
so it's exactly the same kind of
curiosity that we as scientists use all
the time whenever we design an
experiment
it's basically configuring actively
configuring some process to generate
something that can be sensed or measured
that
that maximally resolves our uncertainty
or affords the greatest amount of
information so
you know
the three of us as scientists uh have
become
um
experts at this kind of formal curiosity
simply you know
just by acquiring uh knowledge about
in the in the particular paradigms or
setups and the fields that we find
ourselves in the right way to do
experiments but you could argue that
that's life
you know in a sense that is the the
infant bubbling uh
it is you know
that kind of sense making getting
actively getting the right kind of data
to work out your place in the world
uh to work out what you know what you
should do next
is one of the most existentially
important imperatives um and you know i
was struck out you know but the
mechanics that mike was talking about in
terms of the you know
the little skin cells left their own
devices have it having a party and
forming balls and wandering around i
mean you know one could apply that kind
of mechanics
to people couldn't you or even even
cultures and countries we're all trying
to find our place and we're all trying
to work out how to respond to those
constraints
people around us at many different
scales
put on our behavior and try and infer
well how am i meant to behave in this
situation
so even if we all start off with the
same genetic code and the same sort of
model of you know
how people behave
the context in which we find ourselves
now needs to be inferred in order to
have to know how to behave in this
context either with a child or as a
mother as a politician or as an aid
worker or a first responder whatever you
want you have to make that inference and
of course that inference
inferring that context requires
the curious behavior that
that
chris had picked up on
in mike's example
wow could could you know what i'd love
to hear is each of you talk about um
what is the
simplest most basic uh
thing so you know hopefully going down
to like
physics prior to life but but whatever
you like what is the most basic thing
that is able to do that because that's
what i find in in talking about this
stuff to other communities the thing
that people are the most resistant to is
this idea that these kind of dynamics
this this kind of uh exploration
curiosity prediction all of these things
that we're talking about that you know
people people think it's it's brains
first and then you can do all these
these these great things i i would love
to hear um you know what you think is
the simplest physical system that can do
that kind of thing so that we can talk
about how far down it actually goes
while chris is thinking about that with
a profound answer
not a trivial answer but a formal um
answer uh i i think it's
um you'd have to identify the um the
depth of planning
um that underwrote the
the dynamics of the behavior of the
system um
in question um and that would be
basically
if you were putting this in a sort of
path integral formulation it would be
the sort of the the amount of time over
which you are integrating your paths and
you're evaluating the best way forward
um
once you move
once you move from uh very short time
scales
um
then the depth of that planning i think
eludes um physical realizations that
could be written down in terms of um
representations in terms of
concentrations and
um depolarizations and the like um and
one has to move to a quantum discrete
time representation so you know
i guess i'm basically making the
difference between the sort of um
the the the kind of dynamics you'd find
in a uh in chemotaxis or a thermostat um
that could be written down as
differential equations in fact
the kind of differential equations we
used in one of those early
pattern formation papers and knowing
your place uh approaches um where
everything could be articulated in terms
of differential equations so that there
is a kind of planning but it's not of
the curious kind that we talked about
it's just following the most likely
paths of at least action so i would say
that they're not cognitive in the sense
that they have planning
um so i put chemotaxis and thermostats
and possibly most viruses probably at a
precognitive
or proto-cognitive level but as soon as
you get to
um
generator models that can roll out deep
into the future and i i repeat just when
you try to implement this in silico
you know using computer simulations you
really have to move to a discrete time
representation um which i think is a
non-trivial thing i mean just for
example remember the sort of the eye
movement example yeah we sense make
by getting little snapshots of the world
every 250 milliseconds
uh it's not like i've got i am a
thermostat and i'm taking a continuous
record of the temperature that is a
continuous i'm actually getting
quantal observations um and i think once
you move to that kind of generative
model or biophysics that entails um the
gradient flows under that genitive model
then i think you're in a position to
talk about sort of planning and
cognition and curiosity of the kind that
would we're talking about uh so i you
know i'd literally put time constants on
this i'd say about you know 300
milliseconds if you've got the ability
to represent the future
300 milliseconds
you know
sorry represent the consequences of your
actions more than 300 milliseconds in
the future then i put you in
having crossed that one of those cuts
um and
moved from from being a sort of um yeah
a virus to you know to to i don't know
perhaps an insect i'm not sure
perhaps you had to go
are you seriously putting the 300 ml
seconds forward or like or is that
facetious
um
it's it's facetious but
but not as facetious as it might as you
might think
i do think that they're
yeah i think there's a
there's one way of celebrating the um
the escapes from pan psychism that we
started off with when you know when mike
was saying what he spends his time
talking about one of the ways is to
commit to vagueness and you know how
many um
how many grains of sand do i need before
this is all becomes a pile um and try
and work out what the uh what the
quantity is uh that defines that
spectrum that we were talking about
before uh along the switch there is
vagueness at some point consciousness of
a certain kind um
arises um but i also think there are
natural kinds that actually have bright
lines between them
and you know
what i'm saying here and i i don't think
i said it before and i probably wouldn't
say it again um
but
unless i've simulated it but certainly
in my experience
qualitatively different kinds of
generative models that represent time in
very very different ways you can get so
mathematically things like kalman
filters that can be cast or linear
quadratic control robotics
and the like that can be cast purely in
terms of futures that are represented in
terms of velocities and accelerations
and higher order motions that are just
in the dynamics and the equations of
motion
uh and you can realize and build these
things you can simulate them and they
behave
in a very plausible way you can get them
to do handwriting you can get them to
self-organize and do all sorts of
interesting things
our thermostat
but that's um
that's as far as it goes these things
don't show curious behavior to do
curious behavior you're really gonna
roll out much further into the future
and in running out further into the
future it's very difficult to represent
the future just using differential
equations unless you move to very very
high orders of motion
and at which point you start to sort of
you know to minimize that complexity
start to articulate things in discrete
time and then the maths and so the mass
the new
the um numerics become much simpler and
doable
and
then you've got a qualitatively
different kind of genitive model you
move from a continuous to a discrete
time a quant a quantized generative
model um so that for me is not does not
allow a vagueness you know there is
actually a natural kind that will
represent things in the moment in terms
of flows and dynamics and other natural
kinds that will represent things um in
terms of discrete not universal clock
time but discrete iterations um and i'm
saying that the you know for for
certainly our scale of interactions and
the way that we sense make i would have
thought 300 milliseconds was not a
controversial um i say that because
that's the cognitive moment it's also
the time interval between the way that
we sample the world not just with our
eyes but when we sniff
we sniff
at a frequency which means that each new
sampling of that well that palpation
with our chemo acceptors and olfactory
receptors is again every couple you know
every 200 milliseconds so suggest to me
there's a sort of discrete
belief updating um and it is a discrete
belief updating that is underwritten by
the way we act the plans have to be in
these discrete chunks of time so that's
where the 300 second milliseconds come
from you see it everywhere
mice whisking they whisk at that
frequency so they touch the palpate
every 300 milliseconds the way i'm
speaking now every phoneme is reaching
your ears every 300 milliseconds or so
or
or possibly less so wherever you look in
our biological scale
that's they does seem to be this
uncharacteristic uh
timestamp that's purely empirical so you
know
the facetious aspect inherits from the
fact that that's that's very egocentric
it's just for things like me i don't
know if it's the things like cells or
quantum physics well it's interesting
because in physics the number three has
an interesting role in fundamental
physics because there's three
generations of
of matter and there's that number three
crops up and it's a mystery as to why so
it sounds like the number 300 or 300
milliseconds a unit attached to it or
neuroscience maybe a a fundamental
constant so chris
what are some of the deep thoughts that
you were having
well i i was just having a visual
impression actually when mike was
talking
and um
of babbling
and
the visual impression was of our our
sort of model of the quantum vacuum
and
when we think of when we think of the
vacuum
or at least i think of it
visually as little things popping in and
out of existence all the time
and
so
one can think of that as a as a kind of
babbling right the the field itself is
exploring what's going on outside of
itself
that's extremely interesting
by
uh
forming a little entity to go off and
explore and then report back
so this is a this is a very different
picture from the one that that
carl gave
in that
um
but i suppose it also has a similarity
or two
that
when we write down
uh a model of that activity it is
discrete
it is operating in a discrete kind
by generating discrete events
even though it's it's modeled in a
continuous space time which
uh
once when digs a little bit deeply the
continuous space time itself becomes
discrete
but
this raises a question for me
which is another of the things that i
think about a lot
um
which is the question of
what we mean by randomness
and
certainly to take a bayesian point of
view where probabilities are all
subjective
uh
it becomes very difficult to say what
randomness might mean if if used in a
way that's meant to be objective or to
refer to something objective
and we model things like
fluctuations in the vacuum as
random
which from a bayesian point of view just
means
it's uncertain to us it represents
information that we
don't have and quite possibly can't get
even in principle
but if we think of that system
as an agent
then of course you're expected to be
exploring its world whatever it is
whatever
uh
exists that's not it
and
maybe
we can really think of babbling all the
way down as a model of of what's
happening in
these phenomena that we
persist in thinking of as random
but we also
don't typically think of these sorts of
systems as agents
this is this is this is incredibly
interesting um
what i heard what i heard carl
saying among other things is that there
is a there is a qualitative transition
when things go from analog to digital in
a certain sense right from from from
continuous to to phase and based on what
chris just said it would just remind us
to to think about the kind of the
quantum world where
at least to my understanding a lot of
things are in fact uh you know sort of
discrete does that mean that really
could it be that that that is the sort
of base state as chris just outlined
with with with that kind of uh
proto-cognitive exploration all the way
down and that these continuous models
that we put on top of it by by by course
graining um you know tiny events into
the kind of macroscopic things that we
see here that's that's an abstraction
that sort of loses the essential uh
mindfulness of it and then we have to
try to rebuild it again by the time we
get to brains but actually all we've
done is obscure the the fact that all
the way from the beginning it was
already digital to start with and we
just sort of put some put some vaseline
on our lens here you know to make
everything look um you know sort of
continuous which then which then made it
look like there was nothing going on at
the lower levels and then somehow we're
we're shocked that we have to recover it
from from somewhere later on
that that's that's what i just heard
from the combination of those two
explanations
it's a very interesting idea and it
connects nicely to the history of
mathematics
or at least the history of mathematics
post descartes and leibniz
which was
all built around the idea of continuous
functions and analysis and calculus and
so on
very very nice convenient mathematics to
use
but uh
obscure it to the surface
carl did you have any thoughts to add to
that
um
[Music]
yeah i i'd probably um
this is why i wanted to hang out with
with mike and chris to learn about
quantum theory because i do think
there's something fundamental about this
sort of
the way that we carve up the world or
the world the way the world can only be
defined in a carved way into tiles or
quantum
discrete things
um
so um i i think that the the the those
observations that we just heard i think
are quite fundamental um and it would be
great to understand
um
everything from the sort of cultural
perspective a discretized perspective
and how continuous constructs rights you
know space and time emerge from that um
you know if necessary um
having said that um i have to say that
um as a physicist i would bring
something else to the table so i'm quite
comfortable dealing with random
fluctuations so for me random
fluctuations are just variables that
change very very quickly
so if i want to write down
um as a physicist so now i don't talk
about a physicist that doesn't know
anything about quantum mechanics um so i
just want to write down a launchvan
equation to describe my universe um i
write it as a mixture of states and
random fluctuations and somebody asked
me what licenses i just saw the
manufacturations are very very quick and
the uh the states are very very slow um
and this is just a natural consequence
of
some kind of renormalization group you
know i i could
make them even slower by going to the
next stage scale and throw each and even
more fast stuff so there's nothing
really if you like
problematic uh from the point of view of
that kind of physicist
um in in the random fluctuations um
uh it just means that all the
stuff that determines flows and dynamics
of the kind that we can
that we engage with and we can plan um
has a particular form
that particular form um
does actually
bring a quantal aspect um to the table
or a discretization aspect of the table
that may or may not be if you like
explained away or absorbed into a
quantum information theoretical
treatment but what i'm talking about
here
are the mathematical image of light
life cycles and biorhythms and
oscillations
and i mean that right from the other the
perspective of a dendrite in my
hippocampus oscillating away at a fast
gamma frequency you know sort of
say 80 hertz through to the
the motion of the heavenly bodies
wherever you look you get the this
solenoidal flow
um
that is characteristic of things that
hang around and don't dissipate almost
immediately um and these are not part of
the random flute version but they become
more evident as you go away from the
fast random stuff into the slow um the
slow uh dynamics um in the sense that
you know clearly uh the orbit of the
moon around
well the orbit of the earth around the
sun for example this deals with very
very massive large things where all the
random fluctuations are effectively
averaged to zero um whereas if you go
down to the quantum scale
um then you know you're not licensed to
do that and these solenoidal flows um
become much less um much less apparent
but our scale
if we uh if life is um
on this reading of physics um
sufficiently classical to have um
oscillations biorhythms
um things that would you need for
feedback that didn't go off to plus or
minus infinity for example just saying
that you're keeping you're circulating
in some states or phase space
in a way that you keep yourself to some
attracting set and as you move through
this you are naturally going to be
oscillating
in a highly non-linear possibly chaotic
way but still the essence is life cycles
if that's the case then the poncharis
section does indeed permit a description
that is necessarily discretized in the
sense you're going to pass through the
neighborhood of various states and
discrete points in time
recurrently
so
that's what i was thinking from the
point of view of a physicist who does
not have the fluency of quantum
mechanics to get back to a discrete
thing but it also i think um
highlights the um
the deep connection between
things recurring discretely or occurring
discretely
being one way of defining another
characteristic of
biological self-organization which is
basically the repeat biorhythms and life
cycles
that have this sort of self-contained
itinerancy because in that
self-containment you've got this natural
resolution of ambiguity and uncertainty
because you always know you're you're on
the same arterial path repeatedly
visiting the states that you once
occupied so that that's what i would say
from the point of view of physicist i
may say something very different in a
few years time when i've learned more
about quantum theory so let me ask chris
could you ever describe that kind of
mathematic physicist's treatment of
dynamics in pure quantum information
theory and that at that kind of scale
well i i think if we if we try to think
of scaling up from
from
um
descriptions of things like quantum
fields then this looks impossible
but
if we think of it
informationally maybe it doesn't look
impossible
now
i'll go back to john wheeler's
notion that a bit is fundamentally the
answer to a yes or no question
and
information the information theory is
about bits and systems that exchange
bits
but
question
do you mind repeating that last part but
what
what wheeler's aphorism
doesn't specify is the complexity of the
question
that has a yes or no answer
so in in your case carl you have an
oscillatory system that
passes after a discrete time a
particular boundary
so
the the system may well be asking the
question have i passed this boundary
and the answer is yes or no
or am i passing the boundary right now
well that's one bit
uh that's a yes or no question but it's
an extremely complicated question
so
it may be that we can
develop
a theory that leaves the complexity of
the generative model unspecified
and concentrates
just on the bit flow
across the boundary
that counts as evidence in one direction
and perturbative action in the other
direction
and and then i think the two pictures
fit together rather nicely
because one can imagine that
generative model operating it that the
general model being the model that
generates the questions
operating in many different scales
where one could think of the scales as
computational complexity
and this gets back in a sense to your
question about language
how
language is a way of posing questions
it's a way of babbling in the world
now this
process of babbling it seems to me as
far as i understand it's like poking and
prodding to test your own self model to
see what's the difference between me and
the world it sounds like that
never stops even though we
call it babbling as if infants do it
does it ever stop are we not engaging in
this right now
and i like this phrase babbling all the
way down
i'm gonna put that on a t-shirt by the
way chris or and it also by the way
seems like babbling all the way up too
because we're constantly engaging in
this so firstly is that true
does babbling have an end
and
and also does it not
presume a self
in order to test the self
what i mean is carl when you were
speaking about
the process of babbling it's the infant
doing something on the world in order to
make a model
but that first part was it's it is doing
something to the world to me already
presumes the external world whereas the
way that i'm understanding it is that
the self is a model but it's also
in your point of view it's something
objective and i believe from my readings
of chris i don't i believe chris is more
on the non-dual end where it's it's it's
that's less the case so i'm unsure
anyway i just said a slew so please
respond to it as you
as you wish
right well i mean just to um
dispel the notion that the self is um
objective no i i didn't mean that i i
meant it in exactly the same way that um
i think both chris and mike have been
intimating that you know from the inside
of a cell or a person or the baby's
skull um
your
self um is
quite a a sophisticated um construct
fantasy hypothesis
that is physically realized possibly
neuronally in some lucky creatures and
some lucky children uh you may actually
find some children never get that far
you know i'm thinking here of people
with severe autism for example who don't
have a theory of mind simply because
they never developed the notion that um
i am a person um and you know what comes
along with that is that
you know if you've got very very severe
autism or you know if he likes other
theoretically idealized autism and that
means that personhood doesn't exist so
you would be i would regard you as an
animate french or you know
some um
interesting autonomous vehicle but you
would never be a person because i don't
i don't have the hypothesis that you
know there are people out there and that
people share certain sort of phenotypic
characteristics and um have intentions
in the same sense that i have intentions
so i just i'm not aware of that because
i just don't don't have that hypothesis
so it's a long-winded way of saying that
i didn't mean to imply
any objectivity here i was more going
the other way really i'm just saying
that
selfhood um
that would be one part of consciousness
and if you
want to associate cognition and
consciousness then perhaps possibly um
that kind of minimal selfhood would you
know would be necessarily part of of
cognition
this is a gift that you have to get by
crossing one of those bright lines
and it's just a fantasy that you bring
to the table to make sense of
all the impressions on your sort of
sensory surface or your holographic
screen or your or your cell surface or
also the receptors you are equipped with
um to sense what's going on out there
does that make sense yeah i know that
mike and and chris you may have a
response to that but i just want to
quickly respond to what professor first
was saying is so
and this is to both of you how do you
then prevent an existential crisis as
you start to study this so for example
carl before you and i were speaking and
i told you about some experiences i had
where i've deeply felt what you're
saying as being true that the self is a
fantasy and this oneness with all this
world being generated in one's mind and
i felt like that was akin to a psychotic
episode and it was extremely
destabilizing and to be quite frank i'm
still recovering from that and so i'm
unsure how any of you all
do this work without constantly
being in a debilitating state of of
existence well existence is the question
here that it's an existential crisis
which i'm inquiring about so how is it
that you prevent yourself from getting
into that how could you say these words
of well the self is is not objective the
self may be a a fantasy quote unquote
but not then be able to to not speak and
look around you in awe and and horror at
the same time
okay so that's a psychological uh
philosophical question anyone who wants
to take that up
i think i think there is a good deal of
existential um
what
uncertainty involved in
uh
in doing what we're doing so it's just
par for the course
right
how do you get over it
i'm not sure when gets over it
i i
think it's more
um
[Music]
being comfortable with it
you know i i i think you raise a really
a really important point and it's i
think this is in a class of
uh
a number of really destabilizing um
uh ideas that one picks up as one gets
older and studies things and there are
many of these i remember as a child
being completely freaked out by the fact
that i realized that you know we grow up
and we become these adults and these
adults bear
some resemblance to the children but
they're definitely not the same thing
and so in some sense you could sort of
see it coming it's almost even even
before you realize that you're gonna you
know you're gonna you're gonna die
biologically someday before long before
that you realize that you're going to
undergo some transition that's going to
you know turn you into a completely
different sort of creature which really
you know has some continuity but maybe
not you know it's certainly not you
persisting in the same way as you are
now right so some kind of weird butter
you know caterpillar butterfly effect
where
you're just not going to be around in
that same way as as you are now right so
that's kind of the first thing you you
realize as a child and then there's many
others that sort of you know you learn
about boltzmann brains and all the
different you know human arguments so
but you know all the stuff that you know
i had to i i did um
i did a philosophy class with my son
when he was little uh uh we were doing
um homeschooling and so i kind of did
this and i realized very quickly that i
have to be very careful with this stuff
because if right somebody who has the
capacity to understand it it's extremely
destabilizing and i think that uh for at
this point for myself uh what you know i
sort of go with with descartes a little
bit in the following sense
i i i'm not depressed by it in the sense
that whatever we discover is is a truer
model of the self than we may have had
it doesn't it i don't i don't think
there's any way in which it makes it
less um it makes us less less less
valuable less interesting less engaging
all of that is still true it's just that
now we've realized that a different set
of mechanisms can now
implement that magic than we thought
right so you may have had so you know
some sort of um idea that well there has
to be some sort of um
different kind of unique process that
makes this permanent self and therefore
i'm this individual and i have i have uh
you know i have true true beliefs and
preferences and i exist in some way i i
don't think you can ever convince
yourself that you that that that isn't
true and that you don't exist it's just
that now you find out that actually
the way you get to be that is by these
sets of mechanisms and they're very
interesting it's the sort of thing that
carl and chris have been talking about
so that's what gets you to be this
individual this kind of individual and
it's kind of amazing that that works but
that doesn't to me that doesn't um
diminish all of the things all of the
things that i thought were true about
what the individual actually is right
your reality the reality of it the
impermanent impermanence is there but we
knew that from the time you were a kid
you knew that it wasn't going to be
permanent so that that part you know you
sort of have to deal with from the start
after that it's all you're learning
after that is just that you were really
mistaken about what it takes to be that
sort of creature you thought maybe it
had to be some magical whatever now you
think that wow it's a set of you know
feedback loops and whatever else so
that's surprising but
that's okay we we learn about you know
we learn about uh different
underpinnings to things all the time so
that's okay but i don't i don't think
any of it diminishes the the the sort of
um uh just the incredible awe of of
being a sentient being i can think about
these things
yeah
just to reiterate that sorry i didn't in
any way mean to demean um our selfhood
or yourself in particular um by calling
it a fantasy i actually meant it
and indeed have written about it um in
terms of something quite fantastic
so we've written papers called the
fantastic organ the brain is a fantastic
organ just because it can produce these
fantasies it's absolutely fantastic
and of course they
you know in relation to our early
conversation the capacity to have these
fantasies which have incredible
explanatory power
if you can attain them and you can
maintain them um is the part of the
complexity which allows us to cross
these bright lines or these gaps uh and
become our cuts and become um closer to
you know to the kind of creatures that
can can even entertain the notion of the
heart problem
just to so
mike i just love that better answer we
don't know what the answer will look
like
i'm going to tell andy clark about that
he'll tell david chalmers
but to come back to the point so i
didn't mean to demean that um
and
you know
phrases that i remember coming across
and
having to learn uh when i was a student
of things like existential angst and
ontological security all of these things
um you know rear their
face if you are worried about these
things but the very fact that you are
able to entertain the notion that you
are not real is quite remarkable um and
i repeat is it is a gift of a fantastic
sort it is a kind of fantasy that very
few um creatures haven't and sometimes
even few people have so there are people
who actually will go out there to try
and
um experience that and to become and
treasure the uh the gift of being able
to make sense of the world as me and by
taking drugs or doing mindfulness
therapy
in order to actually get to a state
where um
so almost a freudian oceanic state where
selfhood is dissolved so they can
experience it and certainly if you've
taken um sort of psychedelic drugs in
sufficient quantity um you may have that
kind of experience that's a
derealization or dissociative experience
which is the realization that
your your construct your fantasy of
selfhood that is engaged and
engaging continuously and for as long as
you live
um
then um you know
if you want to appreciate that then you
have to experience the you know
the alternative hypothesis uh so you
know
experiencing derealization or this is
depersonalization
is actually i think
one really important step to
self-understanding so i don't see it as
at all threatening nor diminishing it's
it's just
part of self-understanding which not
everybody gets
the opportunity to indulge i mean i mean
in some you know in some sense the most
destabilizing thing of all ought to be
just the bare facts of developmental
biology when you learn that you are in
fact not some sort of uh un indivisible
monadic whatever which i don't even i'm
not even sure what that would entail if
you were but but the fact that we are
all like all intelligence is our
collective intelligences we are all made
of parts and the idea that you used to
be this quiescent oocyte this little bag
of chemical reactions that did very
little and then very slowly sort of step
by step you turned into whatever you are
now if that's not destabilizing i don't
know what is because just knowing
nothing knowing nothing else about
evolution or i mean to me developmental
biology is sort of like the the you know
the queen of of all the sciences because
just that fact that you go from from
from chemistry and physics to mind in in
nine months plus to however many years
it takes uh and that and that you are
literally a collection of cells that you
could see in pond water more or less is
just if you know you're you're a bunch
of cells in the trench coat you know
like the in the cartoons like if if
that's not destabilizing i don't know
what i don't know what else is
so quickly just i know we have to get
going and i'd like to wrap
with a set of
brief questions
but quickly carl and perhaps well anyone
who would like to answer what is it that
separates those who are depersonalized
or go through certain psychotic episodes
from
what is it that separates those who are
fortunately like myself where it's
abating and i'm able to function and i'm
able to have friends and so on versus
those who go into
a ward
because obviously those issues can like
you mentioned it's a gift
for some it's not a gift i felt like for
myself would i don't want that gift to
go i'll return that gift i wish there
was a receipt with it but and i still
actually feel like that but for some
obviously it's it's it's a horrible and
persistent feeling so what is it that
separates them
well i'll answer from the point of view
of a
psychiatrist with a with with a
commitment to sort of a mechanistic or
theoretical uh understanding i i think
it's um the inability to resolve the um
the uncertainty that is
attends
entertaining the dual hypothesis that i
may exist or i may not exist as me
but as soon as you increase your
hypothesis space you naturally induced
uncertainty
an ambivalence and
a kind of ambiguity
so it is exactly the same if you like um
we're talking about the same imperatives
that we've been talking about all along
which is to resolve uncertainty resolve
ambiguity to make the most sense of
things so if you've entertained this
hypothesis that you know you are not you
and you are you and you can't fully
resolve that then you will
find yourself in a state of chronic
uncertainty that unfortunately does have
pathological consequences um i'm not
sure that being in a psych ward is
necessarily too pathological i mean you
know
there are ways to live very nicely and
constructively and fantastically in
psych wars and i've done i spent two
years in the therapeutic community um
but there will be other sequelae of
an inability to resolve uncertainty
they're expressed clinically and
physiologically in terms of anaesthetic
load and the like and chronic stress and
the like which can be very unpleasant uh
and ultimately can have physical
consequences from the point of view you
know the effects on your body so the
question now is why can't some people
resolve that uncertainty i think it's
then a question of the
the
biophysical
processes that enable you to update your
beliefs and build good models of of your
world and that
again this is a very pragmatic answer
from the point of view of you know of of
clinical
of a clinician um
probably the answers lie in the way that
your brain has assembled itself
to
coordinate and attend to various sources
of evidence um and the it looks at the
mechanisms that underwrite that ability
to deploy attention
rest very much upon neuromodulating
neurotransmitters and the kind you you
know you'll have heard about in the
popular media and will have read about
things like dopamine serotonin um and
indeed um
oxytocin uh all the drugs that are
either used or the targets of um
psycholytics or psychedelics or
psychometics or drugs that are used to
try and control some of these feelings
and some of these signs and symptoms
specifically that attend um anxiety
disorders and
depression
so you know understanding the and this
is the not the feedback loops that do
self-organization in a developing embryo
but
the same kinds of mechanisms that do the
feedback loops and self-organization of
different um structures within the brain
um that can be construed as blankets
within blankets or holographic screens
within holographic screens or cells
within cells um or um complying the same
principles but in the particular
instance of the brain doing this and
understanding the neurochemistry and the
biophysics of this fundamental
sense-making self-organization
um it turns out that these are certain
these neurochemical messages um
are
particularly important in resolving that
kind of uncertainty and it may be that
you are have either taken drugs or you
have just grown up to not be able to
deploy these neurotransmitters possibly
properly um again leading us to well how
would you gain control of it
well you might want to do mindfulness
training meditation and the like that
just internal attention state training
basically to mentalize
how you deploy your attention
mike i know that you had a set of
questions that you're eager to ask
both carl and chris did you already get
to all of them
uh well that would be impossible but i
got to uh i get to men i get too many of
them most of the important ones i
learned i learned a massive amount today
this has been just amazing um but i will
be um pestering both of them with
additional questions in uh you know
years to come
great
to end i actually i have a question that
i didn't email you that just occurred to
me as you all were speaking it's
something that professor levin that you
said what are some aspects of your field
maybe their theories or concepts that
your peers are extremely resistant to
but you are not
wow um
i don't know if we got uh time for all
that but that's a lot that's a that's a
lot of stuff um i mean the most basic
there are many i mean the most basic
thing is this notion of uh profound
symmetries between these fields uh you
know this idea that you can um that you
can you can basically import uh
concepts and strategies from cognitive
neuroscience or behavioral science and
deploy them in other spaces
developmental biology and metabolism
that you can that it even makes sense to
talk about um you know goals memories uh
planning navigation uh all of these
kinds of things outside of what we're
used to which is some you know rat in
the maze or something like this so so
that continuum this idea that it goes
that that something important goes all
the way down or maybe a long way down
even if not all the way down that that
that is uh in in in a few circles that's
okay in most circles that that i would
deal with that's just that's just
complete you know complete heresy um
yeah there are many others but that's uh
that's kind of a basic one
chris
well i i think that mike really nailed
it with that answer
and um
i would say
yes it's it's not
a popular idea that
physics and biology and psychology are
actually all more or less the same
science
but
uh i think that they are
[Music]
professor fristen
yeah well that would be my favorite
heresy i'm just going to agree with with
mike and chris you know the physics
biology psychology they're all the same
thing and i just wanted to end by saying
uh you know heresy i'm not so sure
anymore i i
you know the number of times for example
i see mike levin cited
in high-end philosophy journals and
treatments
um suggests to me that in fact it's
going to be the minority um in at least
in a few years time that that don't
subscribe to this more holistic um um
encompassing um and i think um correct
way of viewing um you know cellular life
sciences but you're more generally sort
of the natural sciences
so
you know who is going to be the heretic
in a few years time i i suspect it won't
be any of us
and i'll end with one that i see
from particularly chris and michael is
it sounds like
without using the word it sounds like
what you all are doing or trying to
understand god or trying to come up with
the model of god and the reason why i
say that is because with looking at a
neuron and saying okay how can a neuron
look around and have some model and know
that it's embedded in something higher
that sounds to me like well if we apply
that to ourselves and continually do so
we would reach something akin to god and
then chris with the quantum babbling if
one can think of it like that well what
is babbling
i know that maybe you all don't want to
use the word god but for me
what i
i have that many of my peers are
extremely against would be to
philosophize about god or to explicate
god or to take god seriously as not an
old man in the sky with a beard
and so i i see you all as doing
something similar in him
i'm happy to be in your company i'm
extremely lucky
all science um
starts with an act of faith with a very
important act of faith which is that the
world is in some way understandable that
we are not just a bubble in this um you
know random universe that just happens
to you know as
a as a total random string of of of
coincidence looks like it's got laws and
then in a tomorrow somewhere you know
while you sleep the whole thing falls
apart and we go back to a random you
know sort of random distribution of
events so we all there's no proof of any
of it of any of that right we take we
have to take that on faith and that may
be for a scientist that may be the most
destabilizing thing if you can't get
yourself to believe that that that the
world isn't for some weird reason
understandable and amenable at least to
some extent to our logic and probing
then then you can't do science you can't
do any of the things that that we do so
so being uh useful and and hopefully
productive in in what we do
starts with that act of faith that is
just completely to my knowledge it's
it's it's it's it's an axiom it's not
based on any evidence that you could
possibly have so so i do think that sort
of underlies everything that we do just
this idea that we can in fact squeeze
some understanding out of what's going
on around us
i'd also think you'd be surprised i know
that you said that it doesn't comport
with the traditional definition of god
but it depends on what tradition and how
far back one goes because there are
mystics of let's say christian mystics
and his
muslim mystics or islamic mystics and so
on yeah and obviously then the eastern
end is much more
mystical
so okay well thank you all so much for
for
thank you so much for coming out to this
and thank you i i've learned a
tremendous amount and i hope you all
have too i i i'm blessed and thank you
so much
well thank you very much this was this
was a very interesting conversation and
thank you very much for putting it
together yeah absolutely this is this is
great great great idea thanks for having
us on
yeah i'm just super pleased super
pleased to have been part of it yeah it
went in directions that i didn't expect
i didn't i don't even think i looked at
my notes my my notepad here and i wrote
some notes but they occurred to me in
the moment okay thank you all mike i
know you got to get going and and
so well thank you all all right thank
you cheers cheers thanks so much bye
everyone bye bye
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you